en el vídeo anterior vimos la relación
entre el cambio de energía libre del
traje y el cociente de reacción q lo que
hicimos fue sustituir diferentes valores
de cv y observamos como eso afectaba al
valor de delta g también vimos que el
signo de delta g nos dice si una
reacción es espontánea o no y también
dijimos que al equilibrio q el cociente
de reacción es igual a la constante de
equilibrio acá así que sustituimos que
en la ecuación y obtuvimos el valor de
delta g delta g fue igual a 0 entonces
sabemos que al equilibrio el cambio de
energía libre es igual a 0 es decir no
hay una diferencia entre la energía
libre de los reactivos y la de los
productos entonces
supongamos nuevamente que delta g es
igual a 0 y vamos a sustituirlo aquí
entonces
es igual a delta g cero el cambio de
energía libre estándar más r por t y
cómo nos encontramos al equilibrio
porque delta g es igual a cero tenemos
logaritmo natural de la constante de
equilibrio ok ahora despejemos delta g
cero delta g cero es igual a menos
rt por el logaritmo natural de k
ésta es otra ecuación muy importante que
podemos tomar en cuenta
delta g 0 es el cambio de energía libre
estándar o el cambio de energía libre
pero en condiciones estándar r es la
constante de los gases que es la
temperatura en kelvin y bueno acá es
nuestra constante de equilibrio entonces
si usamos esta ecuación eso significa
que nos encontramos al equilibrio es
decir que delta g es igual a 0 y sabemos
que al equilibrio la constante de
equilibrio
y nos puede dar información sobre la
mezcla reacción ante es decir si tenemos
más productos o más reactivos en el
equilibrio entonces esta ecuación
relaciona a la constante de equilibrio
acá con delta g 0 el cambio de energía
libre estándar por otro lado si tratamos
de saber si una reacción es espontánea
tenemos que usar esta ecuación de arriba
y calcular el valor de delta g entonces
si queremos saber si una reacción es
espontánea o no podemos usar esta
ecuación pero si queremos saber la
relación de productos y de reactivos al
equilibrio entonces podemos usar esta
ecuación pues esa relación tiene que ver
con el cambio de energía libre del taj
es cero
ahora calculemos algunas constantes de
equilibrio recuerden para cada
temperatura específica tenemos una
constante de equilibrio entonces vamos a
calcular la constante de equilibrio para
esta reacción a 298 kelvin esta es una
reacción para sintetizar amoniaco y a
298 kelvin o 25 grados celsius el cambio
de energía libre estándar delta g 0 es
igual a menos 33 kilos
jules entonces escribamos la reacción
que relaciona a delta g 0 y acá delta g
0 es igual a menos
rt por el logaritmo natural de que ahora
delta g 0 es igual a menos 33 kilos
jules vamos a escribir menos 33.0 pero
vamos a convertirlo sachs urss
multiplicamos por 10 a la 3
está en giles y esto es igual a menos la
constante de los gases que es 8.314
jules / mol por kelvin por eso
necesitábamos que esto estuviera en
jules por mol ok para esta reacción del
traje 0 es igual a menos 33.0 kilo jules
y podemos decir kilo georges jules por
moll de reacción así las unidades son
consistentes ahora la temperatura es de
298 kelvin así los kelvin se cancelan y
finalmente por el logaritmo natural de k
la constante de equilibrio que es lo que
queremos calcular usemos la calculadora
empecemos con el valor de delta g 0
menos 33.0 por 10 a la 3
y esto lo vamos a dividir entre menos
8.314 y también vamos a dividir entre
298 esto es igual a 13.30 y 2 entonces
13.32 y todas las unidades se cancelan
esto es igual a logaritmo natural de la
constante de equilibrio que ahora como
despejamos acá bueno podemos aplicar un
anti logaritmo en ambos lados apliquemos
el factor exponencial
del lado izquierdo nos queda el ala
13.32 y del lado derecho nos queda
el logaritmo natural de acá esto se
cancela y nos queda que acá es igual a y
elevada a 13.30 y 2 vamos a calcular eso
a las 13.32 es igual a esto es 6.1 por
10 a la 12 345 entonces 6.1 por 10 a las
5 y como estamos trabajando con gases
podemos escribir café en nuestra
constante de equilibrio entonces
obtuvimos una constante de equilibrio
mayor a 1 y obtuvimos este valor a
partir de un valor negativo de delta que
se mire
delta g 0 es negativo entonces cuando
delta g 0 es menor a 0 es decir cuando
delta g 0 es negativo obtenemos que la
constante de equilibrio k es mayor a 1 y
eso que nos dice sobre la mezcla
reacción ante bueno esto nos dice que al
equilibrio los productos son más
favorecidos que los reactivos así que la
mezcla reacción ante al equilibrio
contiene
más productos que reactivos y todo esto
lo sabemos
usando el valor de delta g cero hagamos
el mismo problema pero ahora digamos que
la reacción se encuentra a otra
temperatura ahora nuestra reacción está
a 464 kelvin aún estamos sintetizando
amoniaco entonces nuestro objetivo es
calcular la constante de equilibrio a
esta temperatura y miren a 464 kelvin el
cambio de energía libre estándar delta g
0 es igual a cero entonces vamos a
escribir nuestra reacción delta g 0 es
igual a menos
rt por el logaritmo natural de la
constante de equilibrio que esta vez
delta g 0 es igual a 0
entonces vamos a sustituirlo 0 es igual
a menos r
la constante de los gases x
la temperatura que en este caso es de
464 kelvin pero como al despejar
esto será igual a cero entonces el
logaritmo natural de k es igual a cero
tenemos cero es igual a logaritmo
natural de acá nuevamente para despejar
acá vamos a aplicar el factor
exponencial en ambos lados de la
ecuación
a la 0 es igual a en el logaritmo
natural de k
y el logaritmo natural se cancela y nos
queda que acá es igual a él a la 0 y el
a la 0 es igual a 1 entonces cuando
delta g 0 es igual a 0 voy a escribir
cuando el cambio de energía libre
estándar delta g 0 es igual a cero k es
igual a 1 y eso significa que al
equilibrio los productos y los reactivos
son igualmente favorecidos hagamos otro
ejemplo
nuevamente encontremos la constante de
equilibrio pero a otra temperatura ahora
tenemos
ming elvin y nuestro cambio de energía
libre estándar delta g 0 es igual a más
106.5 kilo jules entonces delta g 0 es
igual a menos
rt por el logaritmo natural de k tenemos
más 106.5 kilos jules que para
convertirlo en yours multiplicamos por
10 a la 3 es igual a menos r
la constante de los gases que esté 8.314
no voy a anotar las unidades para que
sea más fácil por la temperatura que en
este caso es de milk el
y esto por el logaritmo natural de la
constante de equilibrio que usemos la
calculadora empecemos con delta g 0
106.5 por 10 a la 3 y esto vamos a
dividirlo entre menos 8.314 después esto
vamos a dividirlo entre 1000 y eso nos
da un valor de menos 12.81 entonces
tenemos menos 12.81 es igual a logaritmo
natural de la constante de equilibrio y
claro nuevamente para despejar acá vamos
a aplicar el factor exponencial y nos
queda que acá es igual
a la menos 12.81 y esto a que desigual
vamos a ver
al menos 281 esto es igual a 2.7 por 10
a la menos 6 entonces la constante de
equilibrio que es igual a 2.7 por 10 a
la menos 6 entonces cuando delta g 0 el
cambio de energía libre estándar es
positivo voy a inscribirlo cuando delta
g 0 es mayor a 0 la constante de
equilibrio k es menor a 1 y eso
significa que al equilibrio los
reactivos son favorecidos así que la
mezcla reacción ante al equilibrio
contiene más reactivos que productos